[Musique]
rassemblement général sur la place
ducale va si le rituel commence à
s'installer
c'est la deuxième édition de ce défi
sportif initiée par l'association nou pa
savent
allez c'est parti pour 13 km de marche
intense dans plusieurs quartiers du
lamentin pas de code vestimentaire
imposé
il faut juste être vu dans la rue ce
n'est pas un vide et insistent les
organisateurs
et pourtant l'esprit du carnaval et
l'art après bois d'inde et acajou
c'est le centre-bourg que les quelques
milliers de marathonien traversent ils
sont en mode débouler un constat
certains novices sont larié ils sont
distancés
[Musique]
vous avez vous avez perdu le train là
non parce que j'ai rencontré des armées
je me suis arrêté et est tout les sépare
de me connaissez pas mal bien sûr on
fonctionne à l'orgueil s'arrêter là non
non je continue je continue au nom
résume réseau plus que quelques petits
kilomètres à parcourir
allez on ne lâche rien la gare routière
de petit manoir
c'est juste une petite pause de quelques
minutes c'était fatiguant surtout la
montée de reboisement est entraînée pour
faire ça va ce 13 km c'est beaucoup du
tout du tout ça fait plus de deux ans
que je n'ai pas marcher notre cheval de
mèches pas comme on le sait a votre avis
il ya plus de monde que l'année dernière
oui y'en a plus nettement plus on
récupère des gens sur la route comme ça
une vie depuis waddell on récupère des
gens comme ça à callebasse y ait un
petit manoir on va récupérer encore je
pense la place d'armes au score à part
[Musique]
c'est une masse populaire
il y à plus de 2000 personnes une vraie
marée humaine
aucun doute le ton du carnaval 2010 9
est donné
[Musique]